han pedido y están trabajando de manera
conjunta para garantizar un corredor
humanitario para que quienes quieran
nacionales o extranjeros puedan salir de
afganistán cuando lo deseen de una
manera segura pero como recordemos y lo
hemos escuchado hace unos instantes de
la propia voz del enviado especial de
france 24 que está en el aeropuerto
internacional de kabul el talibán tiene
el control de este aeropuerto no a
certeza de cuándo podrá volver a ser
abierto así que esa es una gran
preocupación tanto francia como el reino
unido- están tratando de ejercer todo su
poder diplomático y político a través de
estas instancias internacionales para
exigir compromisos al tal iván también
el reino unido- les ha dicho a sus
ciudadanos que se mantienen en
territorio afgano y a los nacionales
afganos que son elegibles para salir del
país que traten de llegar a las
fronteras de terceros países como irán y
pakistán para que entonces puedan ser
evacuados pero esta es una de las
opciones más difíciles dado que como lo
sabemos el talibán tiene hace varias
semanas en contra el absoluto del
territorio la gran pregunta que surge
ahora es que van a ser los países
occidentales las potencias para exigir
al talibán que respete los derechos
humanos de su población sobre todo
cuando cada día más se conocen más
violaciones a los derechos de éstos
justamente ahora que el talibán está en
el poder occidente va a reconocerlo como
gobierno
el reino unido ha dicho que hay que
aceptar la nueva realidad de ese país y
por ello le ha pedido a todos los países
del mundo a que ninguno de manera
unilateral o rápidamente
reconozca al talibán como gobierno sin
antes exigir un mínimo de respeto por
los derechos humanos de la población
respeto y derechos para que las niñas y
las mujeres puedan seguir educándose y
trabajar para que éste no se convierta
en un país que da protección y seguridad
a organizaciones terroristas como isis o
al qaeda